[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous le 78 sport est de retour
pour une nouvelle saison 26 minutes
d'images de reportage d'interview et de
matchs et pour commencer une fois n'est
pas coutume place au basket une page ce
tourne à l'Étoile sportive des chemineau
de trappe relégué en National 3 les
dirigeants historiques ont quitté le
navire le nouveau président Jacques
Michely va nous expliquer ce nouveau
départ N nous nous sommes rendus
également à versaill pour suivre la
préparation des féminines de l'Entente
le chaîn et Versailles nouveau staff
nouvell recrue vous saurez tout avant la
reprise de la Nationale 1 et dans ce 78
sport nous reviendrons sur la formidable
épopée de Théo bourdon ce Guill en
courtois que vous voyez à l'image de 25
ans a parcouru plus de 16000 km à
travers l'Europe à vélo et en un an et
puis évidemment en fin d'émission tous
les résultats du weekend mais tout
d'abord place au dossier que nous
suivons depuis plusieurs années je veux
par parler bien sûr du Vélodrome nous
l'avons découverte il y a tout juste
quelques heures la piste au record du
vélodrome de 50 ans en iine est en train
d'être posée nous vous proposons les
premières images exclusives avec Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud ils la font naître latte après
lat depuis 2 semaines une douzaine
d'ouvriers s'attellent à la tâche à coup
de marteau pour donner vie à la piste au
record du vélodrome de 50 ans en Yveline
250 m de long pour 8 m de large l'anneau
sera unique au monde avec une pente plus
importante qu'ailleurs une inclinaison
de 44° la piste permettra au cyclistes
de monter plus haut et de prendre plus
d'élan pour faire tomber les records du
monde et c'est aussi dans sa composition
même que ce pain venu tout droit de
Sibérie délivre ses secrets il a la
particularité d'être une essence très
dure de croître très lentement et donc
d'être très peu soumis aux variations
d'hydrométrie c'est un des matériaux qui
permet aussi d'avoir le plus de
rendement donc de de restituer l'énergie
des coureurs et ce qui est très
important pour pouvoir gagner de la
vitesse et des kilomètresh cet écrin de
bois réalisé par l'architecte Ralph
schourman coûte environ 1 million
d'euros l'enceinte accueillera près de
5000 personnes et d'éventuelles
compétition de basket ou de volleyball
pourrait s'y
dérouler avant de parler du du basket
attrape Théo vous vous avez fait un tour
d'Europe mais là ça doit vous faire
rêver aussi ce vélodrome non exactement
c'est ce que j'étais en train de dire à
l'instant tout à fait en plus j'ai des
vélos adaptés à la pratique du Vélodrome
donc je serais peut-être l'un des
heureux participants sur le vélodrome on
reviendra sur votre tour d'Europe à vélo
tout à l'heure tout d'abord j'en parlais
hein dans les titres la fin de saison a
été compliquée à trrape entre relégation
en National 3 possible en tout cas
relégation une première depuis 12 ans
nouvelle présidence et recours devant la
Fédération les C antinois ont connu un
été pour le moins mouvementé et le
nouveau président Jacques Michelin nous
fait l'amitié d'être présent parmi nous
pour pour expliquer cette situation
bonsoir à vous bonsoir alors avant de
parler de de votre parcours revenons sur
cette situation un peu spéciale du côté
du club de trap prolégation ça une
première depuis 12 ans nouvelle
présidence avec vous c'est une page
historique qui se tourne là non je ne
sais pas si c'est une page historique
mais dans tous les cas ça représente une
un tournant je dirais quand même dans
l'histoire du club ça c'est c'est
certain mais ce n'est pas en fait
tellement la la Nationale 2 ou 3 qui
représente le tournant ce qui représente
le tournant le plus important c'est
notre projet de club
qui lui je crois est vraiment représente
vraiment une nouvelle page historique il
va y avoir des changements fondamentaux
sur ce projet de club dont vous parlez
tout à fait ce projet de club nous avons
eu également le plaisir de voir qu'il
était validé par le CNDS a mon dit le
ministère des sports sur le département
et il consiste à dire que pour qu'un
enfant et bien a les meilleures chances
de bien apprendre à l'école il faut
qu'il ait le cerveau et l'ensemble du
corps bien oxygéné
le sport est là pour ça d'habitude on a
on a l'habitude de dire que le sport est
là pour faire des des des des corps bien
faits nous pensons qu'il est aussi là
pour faire des têtes bien faites pour
recevoir l'ensemble de de de de
l'enseignement mais ce n'est pas
seulement cela nous pensons aussi que
pour bien pratiquer un sport collectif
notamment un sport collectif très
complexe comme le basket il est
nécessaire d'avoir des notions
abstraites scolaires bien élaboré mais
pour pouvoir définir ce ce projet de
club il faut aussi que votre situation
la situation de votre équipe première
votre équipe Fanon qui était en National
2 soit résolu et à l'heure actuelle ce
n'est pas le cas puisque vous avez
formulé un recours devant la Fédération
Française de Basket et aussi un recours
maintenant contentieux devant le
tribunal administratif alors
expliquez-nous un petit peu bah quelle
est la raison de de cette démarche et
bien tout d'abord une chose c'est que si
nous voulons convaincre les enfants
de faire du basket dans l'esprit du
sport dans les valeurs du sport et pour
qu'ils en soient convaincus de leur
possibilité de de bien pratiquer avec
succès l'apprentissage scolaire et bien
encore faut-il que les adultes que nous
représentons les autorités que nous
représentons et bien soitent elles-même
porteuses de ces valeurs or dans
l'affaire qui nous a occupé durant toute
l'année 2012-23 ça n'a pas été le cas
vous voulez dire que vous avez subi des
pressions arbitrales ce genre de chos
pendant la pendant la saison nous avons
disons très gentiment que nous avons
subi des pressions arbitrales disons des
injustices tout à fait continues durant
tout toute toute
l'année qui on fait que nous étions en
situation
difficile effectivement au classement
cependant ça n'est pas le tout nous
avons
également subi comment eu un un
traitement un peu particulier
notamment notre notre coach de National
2 sur le terrain je le rappelle
d'ailleurs votre coach Mostapha il
lafidi qui est qui est suspendu pour
pour pour de matchs qui était suspendu
suspendu pour de matchs mais c'est
peut-être dû aussi à des situations de
match des conséquen de de défaite qui
font que peut-être que le le staff n'est
plus si serein que ça non à l'évidence
c'est vous avez raison que un climat
interne qui qui est entamé de par une
situation problématique forcément que
l'ensemble des acteurs ne se trouve plus
dans une situation de sérénité propice
au meilleur résultat tout ça est clair
est évident hein que cela a pu user
également les nos nos nos nos premiers
responsables du club ça me paraît
également tout à fait évident hein oui
dans 3 semaines là le championnat
reprend ses droits il faut quand même y
penser c'est la Nationale 3 pour
l'instant en tout cas quelle est
l'ambiance au sein de l'équipe première
dans le staff le staff est conforté
d'ailleurs dans dans son rôle alors vous
conservez Mustapha et lafidi plus que
jamais nous pensons que c'est non
seulement un bon entraîneur mais un
entraîneur exceptionnel ah pourant pour
l'instant sur la saison dernière c'est
un peu compliqué de le dire puisque vous
avez fini 12 non non puisqueen fait si
nous avons porté un recours des recours
auprès de la Fédération c'est par
justement la situation de la justice qui
lui a été
faite je je pourrais rapporter plusieurs
plusieurs exemples concret d'incident je
sais pas si j'ai le temps de deux très
très rapidement bon et bien euh un
premier exemple
euh monsieur affidi s'adresse à
l'arbitre l'arbitre lui dit vous n'avez
pas la parole il dit mais tout de même
il dit seul le le coach a la parole il
dit mais je suis le coach faute
technique on croit rêver et lorsque nous
avons
voulu
porter un recours à cette autrement dit
faire faire une annotation sur la faille
de match comme par hasard nous n'avons
pas eu accès à la fin de match vous
pensez donc que votre recours
peut-êtreoutire ça c'est un premier
point deuxième exemple ce que vous vous
m'avez proposé d' donner deux un
deuxième exemple les les fautes qui ont
été adressées à notre équipe étaient
incommensurablement plus nombreuses que
celle de l'adversaire si bien que nous
avions cinq joueurs il ne restait plus
que c joueurs sur 12 qui était autorisé
à rentrer sur le terrain dont un qui
était blessé donc on met quatre joueurs
sur le terrain puisqu'il n'y avait plus
cinq joueurs à même de le faire
l'arbitre intervient en disant
euh il il me faut cinq joueurs et il est
il n'a pas cinq fautes on dit mais il
est blessé le
le le comment le kiné de l'équipe
adverse était venu le voir
a dit effectivement il faut pas qu'il
faut pas qu'il joue donc notre notre
coach a dit je ne veux pas entamer sa
santé donc il ne rentrera pas faut
technique pour revenir outre ces ces
recours évidemment il y a votre votre
avenir vous puisque maintenant vous êtes
président de de l'Entente en trappe au
niveau de l'étoile des cheminaux de
trappe vous prenez la suite de
Jean-Christophe Buron qui était quand
même un président un peu historique au
sein du club c'est comment ça s'est
décidé justement ce cette prise de
fonction et bien à vrai dire dès le dès
la dernière assemblée générale en
novembre dernier donc pardon en
décembre et
bien il avait été il avait été convenu
qu'il y aurait une année de transition
parce
que Jean-Christophe voulait
effectivement se retirer parce qu'il
avait des obligations professionnelles
lourdes donc c'est un retour enfin c'est
un départ plutôt volontaire ce n'est pas
à cause de la de la de la descente qu'
qu'il est parti céit prévu c'était prévu
voilà la la saison bien sûr n'a pas
amélioré les
choses il est vrai que cela a détériorer
l'ambiance au sein du du ce comité
directeur où j'étais à cette occasion
désigné enfin élu pardon euh président
vice-président président VO qu'est-ce
que vous faisiez avant d'être
intronisé Président je suis le le plus
vieil adhérent du club de
trappe beaucoup ne le savent pas ça fait
47 ans que j'ai signé ma première ma
première licence et j'ai été
aussi le premier entraîneur qui a
participé à la remontée de trappe qui
était au plus bas niveau des de pratique
et de résultats et de nom il y avait il
y avait 6 joueurs en tout dans le club à
cette époque en 67 vous parlez de
remontter une dernière question sur
cette nouvelle saison si c'est la
Nationale 3 l'objectif est clair c'est
la remontée en National 2 bien sûr nous
avons nous avons recruté une équipe avec
la sentiment plein et entier des joueurs
pour pratiquer en National 2 et pour
monter en National 1 ah l'objectif
éclair et annoncé en tout cas merci
beaucoup Jacques Michel d'être venu sur
le plateau donc et donc à forceis si
nous sommes en 3 monter en deux
évidemment merci beaucoup en tout cas
Jacques Michelet d'être venu et puis à
bientôt on suivra évidemment la saison
de trappe du côté du gymnase MAEt merci
beaucoup merci au revoir pour les
féminines de l'Entente le chîn et
Versailles le défi est tout autre cette
saison après leur montée historique en
National 1 en juin dernier les Yves
linoises se vont se battre pour le
maintien cette année nouvelle joueuse
nouvel encadrement nous avons fait le
point il y a quelques jours image de
Jonathan villman clochepied pied droit
première échelle ga pied pied gauche deè
échelle il est le nouvel homme fort de
l'Entente le chînet Versailles Stéphane
Rollet a débarqué cet été tout droit de
Franconville dans le valdoise et du Pôle
Espoir Féminin régional épaulé par Cyril
Marco s'il n'est pas venu les mains
vides sur le banc ibinois quelques
anciennes joueuses de Franconville font
partie du voyage Diana Gandega
internationale malienne qui a participé
aux Jeux olympiques de 2008 et Mélanie
beet passé par les équipe de France
Jeune un recrutement malin qui semble
prendre le tempo du groupe pour
l'instant très bon état d'esprit bon un
nouvel entraîneur c'est toujours
particulier surtout quand on remplace un
entraîneur qui a vécu une montée le
groupe est peut-être un peu timide mais
là non tout se passe bien a priori après
c'est au JUSE de vous dire ça se passe
super bien les filles elles sontes sont
sympas bon il y en a que je connaissais
déjà un petit peu d'avant par le BIA des
compétitions Diana j'ai joué avec elle
l'année dernière donc ça facilite aussi
l'intégration on narrive pas tout seul
quand on est sur une série de victoires
comme ils ont fait avec une montée
forcément on a toujours dans dans
l'enthousiasme et dans l'enjoie cette
réussite après il faut qu'elle perdure
dans le au chapitre style de jeu
l'ancien entraîneur vin Bardic qui a
arrêté sa carrière et Stéphan Rollé
aurait pu bien s'entendre les
ivelinoises joueront comme la saison
dernière avec une défense très agressive
et une circulation de balle où les
joueuses devrait pouvoir s'exprimer mais
pour l'instant place au travail ne pas
se blesser surtout reprendre
tranquillement donc on avit beaucoup de
physique la semaine dernière on touj le
ballon cette semaine on est plus dans la
préparation du collectif et défensif et
offensif et commencera les matchs
amicaux en fin de semaine prochaine pour
voir où on en est B voilà l'idée c'est
qu'on soit prêt pour les deux 2e 3e
match du championnat puisqu'on sera
comme toutes les équipes en rodage le
LCV pourra s'appuyer encore quelques
mois sur C cil d'encer la pivot
historique du club qui n'a pas encore
repris l'entraînement fera une dernière
PIST jusqu'en décembre avant de quitter
les parquets pour assurer le maintien en
National une premier test ce jeudi en
amical face au club TCK de Carat troup 9
plus de 16000 km en un an 20 pays
parcourus parti en août 2012 th au
bourdon vous êtes rentré il y a quelques
semaines mi-août exactement après un
périple inédit comment on décide de
partir à vélo comme ça faire le tour
d'Europe et ben ça a toujours été je
dirais un rêve pour moi de de voyager de
partir découvrir de nouveaux horizons et
j'ai partagé ce rêve avec un ami à moi
de de longue date et nous avons décidé
donc ensemble de de partir à à l'assaut
des des routes d'Europe pendant une
année donc c'est un projet un peu fou il
y avait un besoin de liberté euh tout à
fait tout à fait un besoin de liberté de
se retrouver avec la nature comme comme
un un retour aux sources si je peux dire
et de revenir à une vie un peu plus
simple et euh voilà et de de de se
retrouver de prendre le temps de
réfléchir alors vous êtes parti avec un
vélo de rando ENF de compte portebagage
et cetera 80 K 80 kg K de de de de poids
et de charge en fait qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire de votre vélo maintenant il
a dû prendre pas mal de de petits de
petits P de petit de petit P mécanique
non tout à fait alors je vais
certainement changer la majorité des
pièces de mon vélo puisque au bout de
16000 km vous pouvez imaginer l'état
d'usure des pièces la majorité des vélos
que vous voyez dans la rue font
peut-être 1000 km dans l'année 16000 km
c'est énorme donc je vais changer tout
un tas de pièces mais vous avez conu
comme comme panne ah j'ai cassé
énormément de pièces j'ai caché dont
deux roues arrière une roue avant un
porte-bagage le boîtier de pédalier en
fait tout ce qui est roulement ou les
pièces qui sont soumis à rue de
contrainte c'est-à-dire les roues euh
voilà donc j'ai j'ai changé tout ça de
nombreuses fois en un an vous avez
découvert beaucoup de paysages quel est
quel a été le moment le plus sympa
peut-être le plus émouvant sur la route
ah le le le moment le plus émouvant je
dirais que c'était la partie Grèce les
deux mois que j'ai passé en Grèce ont
été absolument for formidable et plus
particulièrement les deux semaines que
j'ai passé en Crète ça a été absolument
fabuleux au niveau des paysages ou des
rencontres surtout des paysages pour la
pour la Grèce voilà les rencontres je
réserveraai plutôt ça à l'Europe de
l'Est j'ai été assez surpris des des
rencontres que j'ai fait voilà et de la
qualité de ces rencontres c'était
l'accueil dans l'Europe de l'Est qui
était surprenantou l'accueil était
exceptionnel les gens non ont très peu
de choses mais sont prêts à tout vous
offrir vous faire manger avec eux on est
considéré presque comme de la famille et
des fois ça a étéit même très difficile
de de faire les au revoirs des larmes
qui coulent alors que finalement on est
on connaî ces personnes depuis que
simplement quelques jours donc c'est
c'est très beau très fort en émotion
vous le disiez tout à l'heure vous avez
été accompagné pendant presque 6 mois à
peu près par un ami d'enfance qui vous a
quitté après vous étiez seul sur la
route il y a dû avoir un moment
difficile une grosse remise en question
non tout à fait j'étais pas vraiment
préparé au voyage en solitaire euh
forcément beaucoup de risques sur la
route quand on pour les campements
c'est-à-dire que j'ai dormi dans la
nature la plupart du temps donc j'avais
peur également des animaux sauvages les
sangliers les chiens j'en ai croisé tout
un tas et donc pour toutes ces raisonsl
j'étais pas vraiment préparé à voyager
en solitaire maintenant je suis rester
positif tout le long j'ai su rester fort
mentalement et euh et continuer à aller
de l'avant toujours voilà c'est une
véritable épreuve avec vous-même
peut-être pendant pendant toute cette
année vous avez peut-être appris à mieux
vous connaître aussi non tout h c'est
vrai on apprend euh voilà on repousse
ses limites c'est ça on titile les
limites plus je les enfin j'ai beaucoup
beaucoups proche des limites voilà
tutoyer les limites de nombreuses fois l
lors de ce voyage et c'est vrai que
c'est très dur dans ces moments-là de
garder un bon mental et et de continuer
avancé donc le le la plus du la période
la plus difficile pour moi ça a été
après le passage de mes parents et ma
copine en Grèce voilà c'était une
semaine absolument formidable mais quand
ils sont repartis je me suis retrouvé
seul à nouveau et pendant une bonne
semaine ça a été très difficile
d'avancer je vois qu'à côté de vous il y
a quelques
souvenirs qu'est-ce que vous avez ramené
alors j'ai ramené avec moi un magnifique
t-shirt qui m'a été offert par des par
un groupe d'amis tqu que j'ai rencontré
c'est le nom de la ville je crois ouais
le nom d'une ville voilà le nom d'une
ville je l'ai ici en en carte postale
donc c'est une ville classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO euh donc
un des des plus beaux endroits de
République tchèque où j'ai été amené
avec ce groupe d'amis ce groupe d'amis
qui m'ont hébergé qui m'ont offert à
manger à boire tout ça sans rien
demander en retour donc dernière
question quand on fait 16000 km en un an
on voyage partout en Europe qu'est-ce
qu'on fait après après bah écoutez je
vais reprendre certainement un emploi
dans mon domaine d'activité c'est-à-dire
l'ingénierie donc j'ai travaillé 6 ans
dans l'ingénierie automobile euh donc
tout d'abord en tant que concepteur et
ensuite en tant que chercheur matériaux
donc actuellement je suis à la recherche
d'un emploi dans cette branche pas
forcément dans l'automobile mais quelque
chose qui me
permette de vivre voilà de vivre tout
tout simplement merci beaucoup Théo
d'être venu bah raconter toute cette
belle expérience et peut-être à bientôt
pour un un nouveau r je sais qu'il y a
peut-être quelqu qu idées pourquoi pas
merci beaucoup avec plaisir merci
beaucoup pour la 5e année consécutive
plus de 400 enfants ont pu apprendre les
réflexe Vita dans l'eau ils ont passé
l'épreuve du sauvenage à la piscine de
la base de loisir de 50 ans en Eveline
un minimum parfois difficile à réaliser
reportage réalisé avec Hod
mozz c'est pas grave reste debout comme
ça 1 2 3 4 5 les bras en étoile ou
allongé sur le dos
Serena tente de garder la tête hors de
l'eau elle passe les CIN étapes du
sauvenage ce diplôme créé par l'école de
natation française pour faire prendre
conscience à ces jeunes de leur capacité
à assurer leur sécurité dans l'eau c'est
le minimum vital le minimum vital
surtout pour pouvoir retrouver le
bord être amené à se sauver lors d'une
chute et voilà le minimum qui permet
justement de sortir sans être aidé un
minimum vital qui varie en fonction de
l'origine sociale des enfants âgé de 11
à 17 ans ils sont issus de zones
urbaines sensible et pour ce groupe de
sainciir l'école faire la bouteille ou
flotter sur le ventre ont été des
formalités facile mais ouais c'était
bien l'au elle est un peu froide mais
sinon plus facile c'était chercher les
anneaux et le plus dur bah en fait rien
n'était dur en fait c'était faile
pourtant sur les 4 jours de l'opération
peu sont repartis avec leur diplôme en
poche ces opérations comme celle-ci sont
vraiment pour pointer du doigt le fait
que nos jeunes ne savent pas nager nous
on a ici que quelques pourcentages qui
réussissent le test environ 5 à 10 % sur
l'ensemble des jeunes puisqu'on en
accueille 100 par jour sur les qure
journées que N sommes à SaintQuentin
plus de 400 adolescents franciliens ont
passé le test du sauvenage l'année
dernière un enfant de 5 ans avait perdu
la vie dans le bassin de la base de
loisir cet été deux personnes se sont
noyé dans les
ivlines avant de passer au résultats et
à l'essentiel du weekend un dernier coup
de rétroviseur sur l'événement de cet
été hein je veux bien sûr parler du du
Tour de France l'ultime étape du 21
juillet entre Versailles et les
Champs-Élysées petit condand dansé
préparé par Romain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ruspini
[Musique]
première fois de notre vie combien sur
le
Tour ah c'était fabuleux franchement là
on s'est bien amusé on a ramené quelques
petits cadeaux des trucs certainement
inutile mais on s'est vraiment bien
marré là on est venu soutenir
Quintana notre colombiens
préféré qui qui ont deè dans la dans les
tours de France ah si si si on on les
suit mon père est super fan depuis que
je suis né on le suit chaque
annéeb
Colomb place tout d'abord au football
dans ses résultats 2è journée de
Division d'Honneur versaill recevait le
club des uliss au stade montboron malgré
une entame de match un peu passiv les
joueurs de David jig ici en blanc vous
allez voir à l'écran ont plutôt dominé
la compre mais ont pêché dans la
finition avec notamment quelques
occasions ratées en fin de match
d'ailleurs cette occasion que vous allez
pouvoir suivre score final nulvierge 0-0
c'est le deuxè match nul consécutif des
Versaillais je vous propose d'écouter le
nouvel entraîneur évelinois au micro de
Patrick Jacques de dixmud qui attend la
5e journée du championnat pour faire un
premier bilan c'est frustrant de finir
un match avec Auton occasion sans mettre
de but que ce soit d'un côté ou de
l'autre sur l'ensemble notamment sur la
deuxème mi-temps je pense que on on
était pas loin de pouvoir avec un petit
peu plus de justesse technique je pense
qu'on aurait pu prendre les quatre
points donc c'est encourageant il va
falloir continuer comme ça avec ces deux
matchs nuls en autant de journée les
Versaillais peine à décoller hein dans
cette saison ils sont pour l'instant 10e
au classement de division d'honneur avec
4 points prochain match ce dimanche à
l'entente saintnois saint-grcien
toujours en foot c'est les transferts il
reste encore quelques heures au club
pour faire des affaires sur le marché le
mercato ferme ses portes ce soir à
minuit et l'ancien joueur de nfle le
château Mamo Koulibali qui vient de
marquer n'a pas attendu aussi longtemps
pour être transféré au hercéence à 31
ans l'attaquant portera le numéro 9
descend et or et va découvrir la Ligue 2
aviron maintenant en aviron livivelinois
Thomas Barou est revenu des Championnat
du Monde en Corée avec une prometteuse
4e place le quatre po léger tricolore
avec le versaillais Augustin mouterte
Guillaume Renaud et Franck Solforosi a
passé la ligne derrière le Danemark la
Nouvelle-Zélande et la Grande-Bretagne
pourtant il pointait en 3e place à 500 m
de la ligne mais c'est très prometteur
avec cette médaille en chocolat comme on
dit côté course d'orientation une toute
petite info au championnat de France qui
se sont déroulé il y a une semaine quant
un returier que nous avions suivi
pendant sa préparation au championnat
d'Europe a terminé au pied du podium à
la 4e place mais pourra se consoler avec
la troisème place de son frère Maxime
sur l'épreuve des moins de 20 ans et une
dernière info c'est les forum des
associations vous en avez l'habitude si
vous n'avez pas encore inscrit votre
enfant dans un club pour la nouvelle
saison il est encore temps rendez-vous
ce week un peu partout à 50 ans en
Yveline à montinilbroteneux au Centre
sportif Pierre de Coubertin au scarabé à
La Verrière ou encore au complexe
sportif de la clé Saint-Pierre àencour
c'est la fin de ce 78 sport merci de
l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter via les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag le 78 sport tout attaché
bonne soirée et à lundi
[Musique]
prochain